[Music]
so my name is
juanie my name is alice i'm oona my name
is elena wusu my name is maxwell vice
there was a few moments in grand army
that resonated with me
it was almost like someone filmed my
actual high school and put it on display
which i liked grand army really
confronts the issues head on
it's incredible and and people really
need to know i felt that
our generation from this show can get
that
it's not just you there are millions of
these stories happening
i grew up in bolin brook illinois
growing up there was
an experience in terms of just how
diverse it was
i had a happy upbringing because
my family was so incredible
there were some struggles just being
one of very few asian people in a
predominantly rich white preppy
neighborhood
i knew i was gay at a really young age
people always called me gay and it
wasn't until
i looked up what gay was that i realized
that was who i was when kids would call
me gay and school i'd be like i am gay
and you probably want to date me and
that's why you're mad
and um it was something that was kind of
hard and scary at first because i was
like
i'm so singular in this school i'm the
only
kid that just can't even help being
almost evidently queer i really
resonated with dominique
she's raising her family by herself
helping her mom she has to hold her own
since she's female and black she knows
that any time she comes out of pocket
anytime she gets mad she has to hold
herself down i resonate with that so
much
you good i'm good i'm good
my family you know they're not even
artists they run a construction company
my mom would bring me to theaters to
musicals when i was younger
and i would watch and i'd be like that's
so amazing this is what i want to do
for the rest of my life my parents were
separated so i did have to go
back and forth between houses i mainly
stay with my mother
in my small suburbian town that was a
struggle
in seeing other people have i guess what
you see as a traditional and full family
and it made me feel like i was missing
something maybe my
first encounter receiving uh
racist comments i was in fourth grade
and then there were these girls who
would like
torment me by chasing me during recess
or whenever they saw me in the hallway
and they would like stretch their eyes
out and go
who am i and it's like at this point of
my
life you know that seems ridiculous but
when you're like
10 that is very traumatizing and i think
ever since then i realized oh
so i'm different and in a lot of
people's eyes it's not a good thing
i didn't go to a regular high school i
was miserable there
honestly i didn't fit in i felt like
there was more for me there was more for
me to see and
i felt like my high school wasn't giving
that to me so when i got the opportunity
to leave and go to community college
i took it immediately so you're you're
19 years old you're a senior in college
yes yes you have to imagine that's
that's different than what a lot of
people experience
it is it is i think sometimes because of
just stereotypes and stigmas around my
gender and my race people expect less of
me
so when i say i state my accomplishments
not to brag but just because
it's the truth um people are
automatically surprised i never
get oh like that's nice more of like are
you sure how
when i first started doing ballet at
nine years old
my teachers were very very strict on me
and i remember i was coming out of class
crying because i wasn't perfect enough i
didn't i didn't have the same body
as the other girls you know let alone i
wasn't even like
the same skin tone i was darker than the
other girls
i was shorter i was chubbier it was
curvy my directors literally put me
aside one day
like after class when i was 14 years old
and they were like
i'm sorry una but like you need to lose
weight
like you know we see you and like you
know
if you want to be in the productions
like you're gonna have to lose some
weight like i just don't think we can
make a costume for you
layla in grand army she felt like she
didn't fit in she felt like
everyone hated her that's exactly how i
felt in ballet
you look much happier than when i saw
you last yeah well
it's at the sky one day in jazz class
my knee just popped and i couldn't walk
i did the rest of the class
in pain almost crying you know it's like
it's like the dancer mentality the
dancer and mentality is
it's okay if you're injured because if
you don't go to class if you don't work
you're nothing if i'm gonna be honest
when you're a dancer like that
college is not a priority college is for
like
[Music]
college is just not for the professional
ballet dancer in in your head they put
you in your head college isn't
you know for that it was like you're
getting your ged you're going to
laguardia community college they have a
theater program
you're doing that being bullied and
receiving racist comments like when i
was a kid
it's sad because our parents moved there
so i could have a better life and a
better future
but then i remember i would hide it from
them
for a while because um i
i i felt i don't know i didn't want to
make them sad honestly
so i kind of tried to you know keep it
together
uh fake a smile when i came home i just
remember one day specifically
um when i just like could not handle
people
bullying me back then and um
i just remember running into my mom's
arms
oh my god i feel so dramatic right now
and um
just being like mom can we please move
to a more asian town
college was an interesting experience it
was a
culture shock in a reverse way right you
hear a lot of people say oh my gosh
college is a culture shock because
you are meeting people of backgrounds
that you never met before
people who don't look like you and i
think for me it was a reverse
where i came from balling brook where
there are all types of different people
and then i go to college
and i'm one of few that look like me
in a huge lecture hall i could count on
my hands like how many people actually
look like me and it got it dwindled
throughout the semester i think grand
army
really confronts the issues head-on they
had like the group of friends
they just kept like throwing off like
some of these
offensive things there is one character
and he's kind of like
you could tell that he was uncomfortable
and i could relate to that in just how
even in the most diverse spaces where
there's all these different people
there can still come those biases even
even from your friends
i joined the student group and there's
this op-ed in the newspaper
that was on the table at this person's
place
that was talking about affirmative
action and one person who was there was
like so adamantly against it
and made a comment to the effect of the
reason why i was at the school was
affirmative action they tried to
backtrack but the
what they said had already been said i
played basketball i played tennis
i was part of student council i was
volunteering everywhere
there's no other reason why i could have
made it into the school besides the fact
that
affirmative action exists or and if
that's what you think of me
what does everybody else think when i
got to college
i came in very excited to be
a part of the university i am part of
when the new
wave of activism for the black lives
matter movement occurred my school
decided to put out a
statement in support however i
challenged that statement in saying
where is this activism reflected within
your
faculty within your students within the
day-to-day community that you claim to
support and be so
active and live about i was pushed
immediately onto the student board of
education
where we review all the acts
of the faculty now and now i serve as a
voice
attempting to find people who were like
me
and bring them to the school i
understood
jason's confusion being in this world
that
gives him so much of being surrounded by
individuals who also don't get the
opportunity
constantly and what do you do when
you're given the opportunity
to speak up but it also means tanking
your career or taking your future but it
means being 110
true to yourself and i felt that
when they say representation matters
it truly truly does i
saw uh this widely
renowned k-pop boy group
and i will never forget you know the
first time
i saw them performing and in these big
interviews and winning awards i was like
hold the
phone like a south korean group
is doing this well in america
what is going on i was truly mind blown
by seeing that because honestly i had
never seen that before
i always kind of felt like k-pop was
seen as like this weird
weird thing you know because growing up
i had to suppress
my love for k-pop because people would
make fun of it after seeing them succeed
so much i was like i can do that too
and my entire perception changed i'm at
laguardia and i start to like it in my
acting one class i'm like oh my god this
is amazing
and then my teacher he's like you know
auditions are up for the fall play
i literally put in my head i was like
you
are going to audition for that play you
are going to get in
you are going to be in your first play
ever that really changed my life because
you know it wasn't the dancer una it
wasn't ballet una
it was actor una it's where i feel like
i can be
actual una so i'm going to transfer to a
four-year college
and get my bachelor's i thought you know
if if i just worked my butt off
if i kept dancing 24 7 if i took no
breaks
i would be the professional and it
didn't turn out like that
and i'm in a whole different pathway i
heard about this party at a diy venue
in my area in bridgewood and it was for
my favorite fashion brands and i was
like
oh this isn't original i'm going to
infiltrate i'm just going to find a way
i was talking to this person at the door
and they were like you know we really
can't
let you in unless you're a volunteer and
i was like oh yeah uh i'm a volunteer
yeah
yeah i'm sorry nice to meet you i shook
his hand and i walked past the bouncer
and i walked in
and he followed me and he walked up to
the boss and said
hey when your interns is here and i was
like
nice to meet you sir my name is max of
ice i guess i'm going to work for you
now
he ultimately told me that we're a
collective of artists
that all have different uh backgrounds
graffiti wood sculpture
painting i resonated with that i
resonated with the liberation and i said
so does that mean if i work here i can
just create with you guys and just
do my thing they're like yeah it's
encouraged just just just come as you
are dress up
bring your art bring your magazines show
us and um it was the first time i had
people interested in my art
and what i brought to the table
afterwards i became a manager at that
gallery and um
we traveled to miami for art basel and
we would go to la and all these other
places and i was seeing all these
different venues all this different art
i think that really quickly built who i
was because i saw things that i liked
and i
took it all these things that i saw from
these beautiful unapologetic people in
the diy scene
helped build vice a lot someone kind of
just walked up to me and was like
i'm going to call you vice she just said
like your personality reminds you of
vice like i can't get enough of you
you're like a bad habit
maxwell is who i am in the daytime it's
who i am when i'm
making the makeup concept when i'm
casting the models from a magazine when
i step in front of that camera
i'm vice and and it's power in that and
everything that i've
built in my queerness and my brownness
my new yorkness
is that you know and people think of
drag they only think of
drag queens and like glitz and glam and
the big eyeliner and the heels but
drag is still a part of my life because
drag is the clothing and the armor you
put on
to get out and be strong the club world
introduced me to drag and it introduced
me to a strength that
i didn't think i was capable of when i
went to orientation
i was alone and i was 110
convinced that i wasn't going to go
there my mentor was actually one of the
main reasons i went to
college despite not seeing anyone
like me and he singled me out in the
crowd and he said
you belong in this space and i wasn't
sure if i made the right decision but
he continued to guide me in the ways of
existing and allowing myself to have my
voice and
be myself but also understanding the
environment around me won't always
accept
that or won't always understand that and
that was okay as well
my company's it's a production company
for theater
and film and we focus on uplifting the
voice of marginalized communities
people who don't usually get a chance
they have a chance with us
i'm doing my master's in public health
but on the other side of things i've
always had an interest in film i did a
summer program
my topic with my group that summer was
housing and homelessness i had no idea
about like really the intricacies of
that issue
and that problem and it's really on
display here in los angeles i was kind
of taken aback by
just how many people are living on the
street part of our project was actually
to go around
los angeles and take pictures that
represent our issue
public health plays such a big role in
people's lives in the way we vote
healthcare food physical activity
housing homelessness all of these things
that
are part of our everyday lives public
health plays a part in
so my goal i want to combine
that that hobby interest of taking
photos
i'm taking biking videos of me biking
around los angeles
i want to get the message out
communicate to people what's really
going on in the world and communicate
how we can fix it educate
quite honestly the the one who took a
chance on me was
myself before now i didn't really
believe in myself you know i felt
i let so many things limit me all i
needed to do was believe in myself
so at this point you know i'm i'm
thriving i'm thriving like more than
anything else i'm thriving
wild card was my first release and it
was
a song about my journey
just limiting myself being limited by
others
suppressing this beast of a performer
and singer my whole life
suppressing my love for my culture and
hiding it it talks about all that but
then how
i'm on the come up and how i've evolved
from that
there's so much going on i feel like
everyone should be more open and aware
to other people
i feel like we should start to learn how
to
learn how to hear one another and just
fully
grab what they're saying we need to
educate people we can't fix things
if people don't know what's going on we
as a society need to recognize
more and more that we are just a
reflection of one another
and you and i are the same
i think we've seen history repeat itself
so much
we've seen so much constant ignorance
and so many patterns that um
we're done and that's why we're loud
what other generation
has kids out there at 11 dyeing their
hair and
doing drag looks and making content
making art and
exploring their gender identity and
exploring their sexuality in
safe healthy ways was because we built
that for ourselves
the older generations didn't build the
world we make online it was us
you